us fachleute wollen schon bald und zwar
sehr bald ausgestorbenen mammuts zum
leben erwecken entsteht so ein echter
jurassic park auf unserer erde also fast
und könnten die mammuts dann durch die
eisigen weiten der tundra streifen und
sogar eine tickende klima bombe in
sibirien entschärfen oder ist es dafür
schon zu spät krieg zum science and
future gegen zwei mal pro woche
spannendes heinz videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
das klingt sehr nach science-fiction
könnte aber schneller realität werden
als bislang gedacht die rede ist von
einem spektakulären plan von us
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern um den genetiker george
church die fachleute wollen mit der
hilfe von gentechnik einer
ausgestorbenen mammuts art wiederbeleben
mit ihrem gigantisch großen körper und
den charakteristisch langen stoßzähnen
könnten diese urzeitwesen dann wieder
durch sibirien stapfen und das obwohl
sie seit knapp 4000 jahren ausgestorben
sind dazu kommt diese wiederbelebt man
muss können uns dann im kampf gegen den
klimawandel helfen das ganze projekt um
george church nimmt jetzt rasant an
fahrt auf denn das benötigte
startkapital hat er nun zusammen ein
eigenes start-up kolosse kümmert sich
jetzt darum diesen plan zur realität
werden zu lassen und das möglicherweise
schon innerhalb der kommenden fünf jahre
wie genau wollen die forschenden
vorgehen und kann dieser plan wirklich
aufgeben gibt es dann eine art jurassic
park auf unserer erde alle spannenden
infos zu diesem thema gibt es jetzt hier
bei klick sonst als im schuljahr das
aussterben ist ein kolossales problem
mit dem die welt konfrontiert ist wir
haben die dna die technologie und die
führenden experten auf dem gebiet so
heißt es auf der website start-ups
kolosse dahinter steckt der harvard
wissenschaftler george church er hat
schon vor jahren die idee entwickelt
mammuts wiederzubeleben doch bislang
fehlte das geld diese hürde aber ist
jetzt genommen etwa 12,7 millionen euro
sollen investoren jetzt zugesichert
haben um das projekt zu realisieren so
richten es us-medien mit dabei wirklich
namhafte geldgeberin und geldgeber unter
anderem thomas tull ausgerechnet der ex
chef der filmproduktionsfirma die
jurassic park produziert hatte doch das
offizielle ziel von george church und
seinem team ist es nicht einen echten
jurassic park auf der erde entstehen zu
lassen geht ja auch nicht mit mammuts
diesen gar nicht alt genug dafür
vielmehr geht es den fachleuten darum
zitat die artenvielfalt auf unserer erde
zu erhalten die idee ist nicht neu
forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten schon
seit jahrzehnten daran längst
ausgestorbene tiere von den toten zu
erwecken vor rund 14 jahren hatten
fachleute zellkerne aus dem letzten
exemplar der ausgestorbenen
pyrenäen steinböcke entnommen und diese
in ziegen eingesetzt im sommer 2003 kam
ein stein bücklein zur welt das
allerdings nach wenigen minuten
erstickte zu den längst ausgestorbenen
tierarten zählen außerdem nochmals
wander tauben und der magen brüder
frosch doch die die extinction bewegung
möchte es möglich machen dass diese
ausgestorbenen tiere wiederbelebt werden
ganz vorne mit dabei der genetiker
george church von renommierten harvard
university in boston manche bezeichnen
ihn als den einstand unserer zeit laut
spiegel ist er zumindest der vielleicht
originellste gehen forscher der welt
sein konkreter plan er will einen embryo
entwickeln der halb elefant und halb
wollhaarmammut ist und dass innerhalb
zukunft das hatte er bereits vor fünf
jahren 2017 auf einer wichtigen
wissenschaftskonferenz der marken
association for the advancement of
science aaas in boston verkündet doch
jetzt werden seine pläne konkret in
einem interview mit dem us-sender cnbc
hatte der genetiker jetzt verkündet dass
bereits in fünf jahren 2027 das erste
mammut kalb geboren werden könnte wenn
man es genau nimmt würde sich dann aber
gar nicht um genau solch ein
wollhaarmammut handeln wie sie damals
vor einigen tausend jahren gelebt haben
sein einzugsgebiet die kalten gebiete
von asien und nordamerika die vol
mammuts entwickelten sich vor etwa 800
bis 600.000 jahren in sieben von 10.000
jahren rotteten die menschen die
säugetiere in großen teilen ihres
verbreitungsgebiets aus einige
populationen lebten bis vor rund 3400
jahren aber nur vereinzelt auf einigen
inseln die tiere waren nicht nur sehr
groß sondern hatten auch sehr kleine
ohren um wärmeverluste zu verhindern sie
waren in der lage selbst bei eisigen
temperaturen zu überleben indem tauenden
permafrost boden wurden in der
vergangenheit immer mal wieder reste der
mammuts aufgespürt beispielsweise gewebe
blut oder stoßzähne und diese funde
haben der fachwelt einen einblick in die
evolution gewehrt doch dieses gen
material reicht nach angaben der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nicht aus um ein mammut zu klonen doch
das material reicht möglicherweise aus
um die dna eines nahen verwandten des
asiatischen elefanten zu verändern um
das ganze umzusetzen wollen die
fachleute elefanten zellen nutzen mit
hilfe der so genannten gen cher christa
kassen haben wir schon oft darüber
berichtet soll dna gezielt zerschnitten
werden und in die zielzellen eingefügt
werden dass er ab gut von mammuts wird
also mit der dna der elefanten
kombiniert eine leihmutter soll dann das
hybride mammut austragen so könnte dann
also eine ganz neue art kreiert werden
einen elefanten mode hybrid das ziel des
projekts so sagt george church sei es
einem kälteresistenten elefanten zu
züchten der aber aussieht und sich
verhält wie armut und damit nicht genug
der plan sieht weiterhin vor dass diese
neuen wollhaarmammuts in einem
schutzgebiet in ostsibirien angesiedelt
werden sollen und damit kommt der
wissenschaftler ag simon f ins spiel er
hat einen spektakulären plan denn er
will achtung das weltklima retten und
hierbei könnten die auferstandenen
wollhaarmammuts helfen dafür entsteht in
ostsibirien ein pleistozän park in dem
bereits rentiere bisons und jacken
pferde leben durch ihre hilfe könnte das
auftauen der permafrostböden
aufgehalten werden es handelt sich
tatsächlich um eine tickende klimawandel
bombe so die fachleute denn hier ist
mehr kohlenstoff eingeschlossen als das
dreimalige abbrennen aller wälder der
erde produzieren könnte das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
doch könnte diese klimawandel bombe
durch die auferstehung der mammuts
entschärft werden ja sagen einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
demnach könnte eine wiederbesiedlung der
tundra nämlich die temperaturen des
permafrosts senken denn das wachstum des
hellen steppengras es könnte durch die
gigantischen pflanzenfresser begünstigt
werden die hellen gräser reflektieren
das sonnenlicht ähnlich wie ein spiegel
und der boden würde so weniger wärme
aufnimmt zudem könnten die mammuts den
schnee fest stampfen und somit das
auftauen der böden erschweren natürlich
gibt es zahlreiche kritikpunkte die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auf der anderen seite weltweit bemängeln
manche sprechen von frankenstein
methoden und wieder andere fachleute
fordern das investierte geld besser zu
nutzen um noch lebende arten zu schützen
spielen sich die beteiligten
forschungsteams wie gott auf oder ist es
eine art korrektur wenn wir menschen
ausgestorbene tiere zurück bringen deren
ausrottung wir selbst zu verantworten
haben eine weitere frage ist noch
umgekehrt könnten die tiere langfristig
in freier natur überleben die fachwelt
sieht das skeptisch denn dafür müsste
das ökosystem der tiere wieder
hergestellt werden und falls der grosse
durchbruch gelingt könnten die mammuts
uns menschen gefährlich werden der
russische wissenschaftler särge sie mov
geht davon aus dass die population in
der modernen welt unter kontrolle
gehalten werden könnte sie werden
niemandem schaden können die mammuts uns
also im kampf gegen den klimawandel
behilflich sein sein sohn und ebenfalls
wissenschaftler nikita 7 auf sagt in
einem interview mit der dpa zu diesen
plänen die chance dass alles gleich
perfekt wird sind gering mammuts werden
nicht benötigt um den klimawandel direkt
zu bekämpfen pflanzen fressen groß soll
die tiere könnten allerdings dabei
helfen faktische landschaften als
weideland vielfältiger und
widerstandsfähiger zu machen und darüber
könne dann möglicherweise auch der
klimawandel beeinflusst werden der
polarforscher guido große zeigt sich
eher skeptisch und das obwohl studien
zeigen dass das in kleinem maßstab
funktioniert doch seiner meinung nach
kann das wiederbeleben der mammuts das
auftauen der böden nicht mehr aufhalten
dafür müsste sehr schnell sehr viele
tiere geben wir sprechen über viele
millionen
quadratkilometer permafrost region die
von einer enorm hohen tier dichter
bevölkert werden müsste die erwerbung
wäre dann in der arktis schon zu weit
fortgeschritten heißt also die
wichtigste maßnahme im kampf gegen den
klimawandel bleibt weiterhin die
beendigung der vor zielen emissionen wie
erdgas kohle oder öl daran führt kein
weg vorbei selbst wenn der große
durchbruch gelingt und irgendwann wieder
mammuts unsere erde besiedeln könnten
superdirektor war ganz anders als wir es
uns vorstellen da geht es um ziemlich
verblüffende erkenntnisse über
dinosaurier anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran